Carrusel de las artes
María Carolina piña
[Música]
un cordial saludo desde ancíe en el
corazón de los alpes franceses Carrusel
de las artes los lleva a descubrir el
Festival Internacional de Cine de
animación más importante del mundo
[Música]
México tiene el privilegio de ser el
país invitado de honor del festival de
animación de ansi festival que reúne a
160.000 profesionales del sector venidos
del mundo entero con nosotros en este
programa El mexicano Jorge Gutiérrez un
referente del cine de animación autor
del colorido afiche del festival de 2023
conoceremos a Rita basulto artista
mexicana en la competencia con humo un
cortometraje de animación ambientado en
la Segunda Guerra Mundial y también en
la competencia de ansí El argentino
Patricio Plaza artista independiente y
defensor de nuevos modelos e historias
para la animación
[Música]
estamos en la edición número 48 del
Festival Internacional del cine de
animación de ancy festival que estuvo
precedido por un drama Que sacudió a
toda Francia el ataque con cuchillo
donde resultaron heridos cuatro niños y
dos adultos el ocho de junio pasado pero
la respuesta del festival fue mantener
este evento con el apoyo masivo de los
artistas invitados al festival y el
público de fanáticos del cine de
animación
[Música]
en Sí en el corazón de los alpes
franceses rindió homenaje a México
alzándolo como país invitado de honor en
2023 la mexicana es una industria joven
que ha crecido de forma exponencial en
los últimos años gracias a la
confluencia de varios factores como nos
explicó Marcel yo el director artístico
del Festival de
la
en América Latina y en México en
particular ha habido un desarrollo muy
rápido del cine de animación también las
plataformas han puesto en evidencia el
peso del mercado latinoamericano y la
necesidad de producir contenidos para el
público hispano Pero además ha habido
figuras mexicanas muy reconocidas
trabajando en animación y en Hollywood
como Guillermo de toro Jorge Gutiérrez
González iñarritu hoy El Talento
mexicano es reconocido Y a eso debemos
sumarle la cultura mexicana que es una
de las más fuertes y ricas del mundo
todos esos elementos hacían de México el
candidato ideal para ser honrado este
año en sí
el festival de anside un espacio
especial a la animación hecha en
Guadalajara uno de los polos artísticos
más importantes de México
[Música]
a Guadalajara en Guadalajara hemos visto
construirse una escuela de animación con
una marca estética muy característica
hay una tradición de la animación en
stop motion y de marionetas que se han
desarrollado allí en los últimos años
Guadalajara ha sido desde hace siglos un
centro artístico muy potente allí tiene
lugar también la feria del libro más
grande en español y el festival de cine
de Guadalajara todo eso ha forjado un
estilo propio que nos interesaba mostrar
en sí
la producción
México es por supuesto el protagonista
de la afiche del festival de hansi 2023
obra del reconocido artista mexicano
Jorge Gutiérrez que se inspiró de la
cultura y de las tradiciones Mexicanas y
con ellas adorno toda la ciudad
[Música]
un año donde México es el país invitado
y que me invitan a hacer el póster el
cartel fue algo genial quise capturar lo
que pasa en la noche que para mí es
literalmente la ciudad brilla con el
talento que está aquí con las historias
que todo mundo está contando y que
llegamos en un lago en México hay una
cosa que se llama las trajineras y llega
una trajinera lleno de todo la cultura
de México a celebrar con con el mundo la
figura principal es una catrina que en
México celebramos la idea de que la
muerte es algo que nos hace valorar la
vida se dice que todo mexicano tiene a
la muerte en el oído diciéndole vive
vive entonces esa celebración es muy
importante para nosotros y también metí
muchos luchadores porque para ser
caricaturas tenemos que luchar mucho
entonces todos los artistas yo los veo
como luchadores y quise meter personajes
prehispánicos personajes de la música
del Norte que está junto a Estados
Unidos del sur de México y representar
todo todo lo que me encanta de México en
un barquito que llega a Francia
en guardia
ustedes dos están portando como tontos
le preguntamos a Jorge nos Explica el
auge de la animación mexicana
mucho el talento mexicano como yo nos
íbamos de México lo que está pasando
ahora es gracias a covid están creciendo
muchos estudios en México y esta idea de
que te tienes que ir de tu país se acabó
ya puedes trabajar en México entonces
grandes empresas están creciendo y se
están haciendo unas producciones cada
vez más grandes en México del artista de
latinoamérica trataba de imitar a la
animación americana a la japonesa a la
europea llega un momento donde en
Latinoamérica empezamos a decir no lo
que tenemos es bueno lo que tenemos es
propio Y por qué no presumir Y por qué
no celebrar de donde venimos Y creo que
eso es lo que está pasando ahorita
Jorge Gutiérrez trabajo con Netflix en
la mini serie Maya y los tres y
considera que las plataformas han
democratizado el acceso a las obras
estamos viviendo en una nueva era cuando
yo empecé a medir los tres y la idea fue
quiero ser como el señor de los anillos
pero de las culturas prehispánicas y
como no se habían hecho proyectos de ese
tipo pues tenían mucho miedo sale la
serie y estuvo en el top ten de 55
países entonces creo que eso levantó la
idea de que nuestras historias son para
todo el planeta antes el público
americano era el más importante y si
funcionaba fuera de Estados Unidos bonos
ahora lo que cambia con Netflix es el
público es el planeta ya no es Estados
Unidos
[Música]
que viva México no y que viva
latinoamérica
[Música]
cerca de 250 artistas conformaron la
delegación mexicana Durante los siete
días del festival el ganador del Oscar
Guillermo el toro hizo una aparición
fugaz para ofrecer una clase magistral
recibir un premio especial entregado por
el festival y defender a los artistas
que hacen animación
los animadores no son técnicos son
artistas y también son actores tenemos
que hacer que la gente entienda esto
el festival de ansiedad organiza cientos
de eventos proyecciones y competencias
en largos y cortometrajes en esta
categoría estuvo Rita basulta una
directora con amplia experiencia quien
estuvo presentando su última película
[Música]
este pez lleva muchos favores esta
historia se llama humo y está basada en
un cuento del mismo nombre que narra el
destino trágico de un niño en un campo
de concentración la directora de este
cortometraje en stop motion hecho con
marionetas de resina papel y carboncillo
nos contó Cómo llegó esta historia a sus
manos
Cuando llega la Fil y veo el libro en la
Feria Internacional del Libro de
Guadalajara que es muy muy importante lo
único que estaba fuera de ese están tan
acotado era un libro y era el libro de
humo y entonces sentí que era no sé como
una señal una coincidencia
extraordinaria que estuviera ese libro y
que estuviera en la mesa poder recrear
esta historia el libro es muy
es sintético es este una estética muy
simple pareciera que es blanco y negro y
con un fondo de papel
[Música]
Nos tocó la casa 48
y sé que los personajes solamente los
principales fueran tridimensionales la
madre el padre su amigo Darío y todos
los demás es como si estuvieran fuera de
foco como algo que no quieres ver porque
duele tanto y así lo solucioné
técnicamente con personajes de kutao
claroscurados este con carboncillo con
sus fondos de acuarela y hacer todo
minimal También la historia no es
colorida la historia es monocromática es
una tristeza enorme humo es una película
producida en el taller del Chucho de
Guadalajara un estudio joven en el que
se hizo una de las secuencias del
Pinocho de Guillermo del Toro tenemos
estudio de carpintería este de mecánica
impresiones tres de tiene todo lo que te
puedas imaginar de recursos para y
tecnología de punta se hizo un gran
monstruo este taller lo primero con lo
que empezó el taller fue con Pinocho
tenemos este pues la suerte de haber
cumplido la misión de una manera
exitosa y creo que nos abrió las puertas
para que está fuera la carta de
presentación del taller
[Música]
mera la mano es mi único amigo
el festival invito a artistas a
contracorriente que buscan otros
lenguajes frente a los modelos
dominantes es el caso del argentino
Patricio plaza en la competencia de
cortometrajes
Patricio Plaza ha escrito y dirigido
tres películas de animación su última
obra es carne de Dios un cortometraje
ambientado en el siglo 16 sobre un
fraile católico que sufre una extraña
enfermedad una curandera indígena
realiza un Rito que tiene efectos
inesperados en el cuerpo y la mente del
religioso
es una ficción especulativa en la cual
vemos un ejercicio de imaginación en
torno a qué pasaría que hubiera pasado
si uno de estos frailes en el proceso de
evangelización que estaba persiguiendo
las prácticas religiosas nativas tiene
que atravesar en su propio cuerpo uno de
esos rituales no por encontrarse enfermo
en este caso Entonces es un poco como
una respuesta a esa imposición de una
mirada única del mundo que se dio en ese
proceso violento de la conquista en ese
sentido es una ficción de género
fantástico pero que está muy nutrida
sobre documentos históricos reales
vengo de una familia muy afectada por la
dictadura militar en Argentina tengo
muchos familiares desaparecidos me
parecía importante confesar a pensar más
hacia el pasado ir más hacia atrás a ver
dónde se originaron estos procesos de
dominación de alguna manera y me parece
que el colonialismo es uno de los hitos
y como eso luego afectó durante todos
los siglos posteriores y sigue afectando
como constituimos nuestras identidades
nuestra subjetividades y como siguen
operando las relaciones de poder carne
de Dios fue producida por ojo raro una
plataforma que desarrolla proyectos
disidentes disruptivos e historias
silenciadas como contrapropuesta a los
modelos y lenguajes más conservadores
la película es una mezcla de influencias
con perspectiva de género desde un
posicionamiento que yo llamo sudaka en
el sentido de que es animación desde el
sur no producida desde el sur por
identidades minoritarias animación queer
y también animación de género pero en el
sentido de los géneros populares como el
terror el fantástico la ciencia ficción
la animación erótica no como todos estos
géneros populares pueden ser
reapropiados para decir otro tipo de
discursos
[Música]
aquí llegamos al término de este
programa especial que les presentamos
desde el Festival Internacional del cine
de animación de ansi Muchísimas gracias
por su sintonía y hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]